bonsoir dans ce set 8 sociétés on va
parler du vélodrome après un nom après
son ouverture quel bilan sur un plan
sportif et financier et quelques
perspectives pour l'année les années à
venir pour en parler en plateau avec moi
laurent mazaury bonsoir bonsoir on est
de conseiller communautaire en charge du
sport et puis en seconde partie
l'émission on retrouvera arnaud courtier
c'est le directeur délégué général alors
que le vélodrome va accueillir dans un
mois presque tous pilat les championnats
du monde sur piste
husseini 35 nations seront représentées
pour ces surfeurs du monde mais on en
parlera dans quelques instants
on va d'abord s'intéresser au but au
vélodrome et donc à son financement
j'ai envie de dire si l'euro mazaury
c'est pas un sujet simple on va essayer
de comprendre avec vous j'aurais juste
rappeler une date en 2003 le projet de
construction du vélodrome a été lancée
c'est un projet qui s'inscrivait
largement dans une construction
d'infrastructures dans le cadre de la
candidature de paris aux jeux olympiques
de 2012 alors paris n'a pas eu les jo
mais saint quentin en tout cas à usson
son vélodrome
vous avez avant d'être content le projet
a coûté quelques 77 millions d'euros
tout à fait être commandés elle était
financée comment ont été financés 77
millions d'euros
et puis on parlera évidemment du fameux
ppp partenariat public privé qui a
permis sa construction et son
exploitation
alors déjà quand on dit que le projet a
coûté 70 7 millions d'euros pour être
exact c'est le coût de construction du
projet et de réalisation des études des
infrastructures et de l'ensemble des
travaux qui ont permis de faire
également les abords s'était pas tout à
fait le tarif initial le prix initial
prévu oui c'est comme grand jour je
dirais que se défendre il ya
malheureusement passer à d'autres sujets
rebond mis en fuite
bref à l'émission spéciale regardez le
cas le cas de la philharmonique à paris
où on est faux à 3 x 5 mm par rapport au
projet d'origine
et ça c'est un vrai sujet français
d'ailleurs c'est comment contrôler et
mieux gérer le coût des travaux des
établissements publics
dans le cas du vélodrome le projet donc
eu un coût
construction 77 millions ça c'est son
coût j'allais dire si on avait été faire
un chèque qu'on avait acquis directement
l'ensemble de l'infrastructure
il a été mis en place de manière
intelligente ce qu'on appelle un
partenariat public privé
alors là aussi il ya beaucoup de
fantasmes sur les ppp partenariat public
privé
il est vrai il faut pas le cacher qu'il
ya des partenariats public-privé qui ont
eu lieu par le passé j'espère qu'il n'a
plus aujourd'hui avec des montages un
match compliqué avec des couteaux bras
durant mazaury pas besoin d'aller très
loin
à la fac de médecine de saint quentin en
yvelines de partenaires publics privés
vient d'être négocié parce que justement
ça avait plombé les caisses de l'ubs et
excuse donc il faut a dit oui j'en
connais des biens je connais des stades
de football par exemple qui ont été
construits pour des équipes qui dans mes
temps sont passés de première division à
des visions d'honneur avec des stades
qui était prévu pour être remplie
aujourd'hui ce vide avant de se
réveiller sur ses 77 millions d'euros il
ya déjà de l'argent qui a été versé le
sang par l'état par le département par
conservera et la castille tout à fait
alors justement on va peut-être mettre
un casque et de côté parce que c'est
vraiment la partie plus technique
j'allais dire du partenariat public
privé
il ya effectivement de l'argent qui est
déversée aussi par le conseil général
donc en ce qui concerne le conseiller
général il ya eu en tout et pour tout
sept millions et demi qui ont été versés
pour financer directement de la
construction et entre le centre social
du sport et la région donc entre l'état
et la région savent après 13h30 qui ont
été versés pour participer à ce
financement c'est-à-dire que grosso modo
on est dehors de 34 millions d'euros de
financements directs pour la
construction du projet à benicio comme
on dit d'ailleurs depuis l'origine et la
casse qui rentrait après dans un contrat
d'arrière dans un partenariat public
privé
voilà ça se passe comment on rend gros
jacking qui est propriétaire alors
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus compliqué
parce qu'on est fier de sa fille elle
est propriétaire le concept de
partenariat public privé c'est quand
vous voulez acheter quelque chose de
construit un établissement public vous
avez deux possibilités
après l'impossibilité c'est d'aller en
partie de l'argent à la banque il y en a
une si vous avez l'argent de vos comptes
mais malheureusement tout le monde sait
que les collectivités territoriales ne
sont pas la situation toujours brillante
à saint quentin en yvelines comme
ailleurs et les choses ne vont pas en
s'arrangeant compte tenu des baisses des
dotations de l'état
c'est un sujet connexe déjà à l'époque
une première solution de l'argent en
banque
c'est idéal c'est comme vous et moi pour
père de famille on veut
sa maison a de la chance l'argent n'en
prennent pas la banque deuxième solution
vous allez les banques
si vous allez à banque lors demandé de
vous prêter la différence a à peu près
une trentaine de millions d'euros pour
construire votre vélodrome
hélas la banque vous le prêtre et quand
la gare d'abord faut qu'elle veuille
bien voulu prêter déjà donc faut qu'elle
ait un plan financement et de
rentabilité qui lui plaisent et ensuite
elle vous prête à différentes au voir
avec des taux fixes ou des taux
variables
je rappellerai pas ici mais tout le
monde le sait grâce aux deux
collectivités ont eu recours à des taux
variables indexés sur des données par
exemple france me semble de choses bien
pires très compliqué avec des
fluctuations qui dépend d'un petit peu
tout et n'importe quoi qui vous amène à
ce que vous ayez à emprunter 1 euro pour
que la finale ça vous en coûte 100 voire
1000 c'est pas le choix qu'a fait la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
elle a fait le choix du partenariat
public privé c'est quoi grosso modo pour
simplifier on va dire que le
constructeur ou ses financeurs vous en
faites à avancer cet argent à la
communauté d'agglomération à l'autorité
publique
et vous allez rembourser cet argent sous
forme d'un loyer ou d'une redevance que
vous verserez à l'exploitant qui
également récupérer une partie de
l'argent de l'exploitation directeur
signé pour 30 ans c'est ça alors quant à
9,3 oui ou un peu moins invention dans
l'exploitation mais sa voix et on compte
30 ans qu'est ce qui va se passer
au bout de trente ans que tu es
d'agglomération est pleinement
propriétaire de l'équipe en charge à
elles ensuite de relouer l'équipement de
l'exploiter en direct d'en faire autre
chose cette exaltation équipement qui
aura coûté 70 7 millions à la base ça
coûtera combien à la finale vous aurez
quelques parfois deux par rapport au
prix d'origine
ce qui est moins que ce que vous aurez
donné un emprunt la banque avec un taux
d'intérêt d'autant plus que dans le même
temps bien entendu vous allez récupérer
des loyers que la qualité de
l'agglomération valeur va manquer c'est
des loyers liés aux occupants du bien et
aux manifestations qui se déroulent
alors on va en discuter mais je voudrais
déjà revenir sur les loyers que verse
link la communauté d'agglomération tous
les ans ses loyers de son de combien
alors est ce que c'est un chiffre au
fixe ou est-ce que c'est indexés sur
quelque chose d'ancien chef qui est
indexé en général qu'un dictionnaire
mans sur différents indices à peine
l'indicé du coût de la construction par
exemple
donc c'est des variations qui sont entre
1 1 et a émis pour cent en moyenne
actuellement avec un loyer de départ qui
est aux alentours de 4 millions 5 et qui
aujourd'hui est aux alentours de 4
millions 8 ce qui veut dire qu'avec une
place à bord d'un lac
ça peut être aussi un indice qui descend
ce qui ne faisait pas les eskers cap est
malheureusement en france aux indices
montrent ce qui nous arrange aussi parce
que l'indicé du coût de la construction
a un impact aussi intéressant sur la
valeur des biens donc certes le loyer
augmente la valeur de l'équipement lui
même continue également de progresser
donc à la finale vous pouvez très bien
retrouver sur une valeur éventuelle de
cession le montant de l'augmentation de
lundi s'il voulait le vendre en 2014
quatre niveaux 8 donc en 2002 en 14 vous
êtes on arrive ici les gens et 2014 à
88,6 qui veut dire que si on multiplie
sur les 30 où les vingt-neuf années vous
avez un équipement qui grosso modo c'est
ce que je disais pas avoir un thé à peu
près le double du montant du coût réel
de construction et leurs banques des
loyers qui sont versées tout affairé à
la castille qui sont des loyers donc
versé par la fédération française de
cyclisme
alors nous sommes très heureux d'avoir
accueilli la fédération ils ont leur
siège
sachant bien entendu vous en doutez que
c'est pas quelque chose qui est là aussi
sortie de rien à denis law et bien
entendu la fédération socialiste faisait
partie du calcul de l'ensemble elle
faisait partie des partenaires puisque
le loyer la fédération française de
cyclisme et essentielles au financement
du partenariat public privé donc la
fédération de verse aujourd'hui un peu
plus de cinq cent mille euros de loyer
pour l'occupation et les usages de
l'ensemble de l'équipement de même vous
avez pour la partie en traitement des
athlètes à peu près 450 mille euros qui
sont également versée donc il ya donc
déduction du montant de loyers du
réveillon et vous avez actuellement à
peu près trente mille euros pour la
partie événements que nous récupérons
partie bien entendu événement qui n'est
est appelée dans le futur car cela c'est
ce groupe et c'est ce que c'est un enjeu
majeur du pouvoir rebondissent et
sûrement pas une question donc les
sources de financement bien compris
elles sont elles sont sportifs par la
fédération française de cyclisme et et
les uns les entraînements des athlètes
l'événementiel vous dites 30000 euros
effectivement c'est assez peu on a vu
qu'il y avait des choses qui s'était
passé en 2014 nous avons vu un festival
tout effort qui sait qui c'est déroulé
festival de hip hop il n'y avait pas le
monde espérait quand même malgré tout
est ce que quel regard la casse qui a
justement sur ces événementiel et qu'est
ce que vous attendez
parce que sur un équipement comme ça
5000 6000 places
on s'attend à voir des stars entre
guillemets
pour l'instant n'a pas vu alors le
regard que l'on porte c'est le regarde
d'être d'abord vigilant d'être acteur de
cette programmation d'être l'aiguillon
notre partenaire qui est vélopolis de
tout faire pour l'aider mais il est
évident que pour nous l'enjeu majeur
c'est d'accueillir dans cet équipement
des éléments de programmation culturelle
d'importance pour y faire venir du monde
je rappelle qu'on peut accueillir que la
même presque 5000 personnes qui a une
fausse qui est très importante qu'on a
une capacité d'y réaliser pratiquement
tout ce que l'on y fait dans un zénith
ou ce qu'on me dit faisait au palais
omnisports de paris bercy c'est la même
logique c'est à dire une logique de
mobilité d'intermodalité complète de
l'équipement
donc notre rôle à nous c'est en
permanence à travers un partenaire qui
nous ont élevés aux polices de pilotage
comité de pilotage de les ai déjà pas
très bon a fait un droit de regard sur
ce qu'ils peuvent programmer proposons
que nous avons bien entendu nous le
droit de regard du propos du
propriétaire voilà corail proposer
n'importe quoi non notre droit c'est
surtout le droit de les motiver à avoir
informations active et je fais confiance
à dessus avec la police et à sion
directeur monsieur sous la gloriette en
réunion je crois d'ailleurs qu'il avait
une réunion pour l'eshop l'adultère pour
préparer la sécurité c'est parfaitement
dans l'idée ce que nous voulons faire
mais je tiens à revenir sur cela il faut
bien comprendre que ce type
d'équipements sportifs ne permet d'avoir
un équipe de fonctionnement que
justement grâce à une programmation qui
n'est pas que sportive
c'est là où on va aller chercher la fois
la notoriété pour l'équipement mais
également une rentabilité pour le
partenariat recoller une compétition
sportive autres cyclisme comment la boxe
on a pu en voir s'est pas forcément
d'accord mais j'ai pas la volonté est
difficile pour un tournoi de boxe sauf
si vous avez un tournoi de boxe du
championnat du monde
il est difficile pour du badminton sauf
si vous avez les championnats du monde
de badminton de remplir les 3500 et 5000
places pour cela il vous faut autre
chose
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste sur l'exemple en efficacité
maladie souvent lent pour lui plein il
doit rester un petit peu de place quand
je dis j'en profite ici
bonjour qui nous regardent dépêchez vous
de réserver vos places il doit nous
rester du jeudi 11 ans part à l'enquêté
mais côté look il vous faut une star il
vous faut des stars peut-être pas la
grande star internationale parce que
après de l'équipement sera même trop
petit il vous faut toutes ces stars qui
remplissent les zéniths de province
l'enjeu d'ailleurs je trouve que la
comparaison est intéressante c'est de
considérer que nous avons aujourd'hui en
banlieue parisienne
un équipement qui n'existait pas qui est
l'équivalent de ce qu'on a dans les
zéniths de province et qui nous évitera
demain de devoir aller à paris je
rappelle que si certains élus disent
qu'il faut effectivement 20 minutes pour
aller à paris de saint quentin il faut
20 minutes à 3 heures du matin si vous
essayez d'aller à 50 aller à paris porte
de la villette au zénith il faudra
plutôt 1h40 donc l'avantagé d'avoir très
accessible entre le rer le train et la
voiture d'avoir un équipement qui peut
rivaliser à la fois en nombre de places
et en qualité d'équipement parce que
pour moi ça c'est leur a déjà fait c'est
trop tôt c'est trop tour c'est trop tôt
il bat la notoriété encore pour qu'un
équipement comme cela a coûté sa place
dans la programmation des tourneurs il
vous faut entre deux et trois ans pour
qu'il commence à avoir le réflexe de le
programmer dans la tournée c'est
exactement le travail que fait vélopolis
en ce moment c'est pour ça que il faut
faire des communications pour cet
équipement et les championnats du monde
de ce qu'ils vont nous aider que cet
équipement soit connue et reconnue
certes une inauguration certes il ya des
records du monde qui ont eu lieu mais
c'est pas encore suffisant il faut que
l'équipement soit connue et reconnue
comme un haut lieu du sport mais
également ouvert avant tout à une
animation culturelle importante
c'est tout l'enjeu pour vélos police et
pour la côte est de l'agglomération
juste pour finir sur ce point nous avons
nous vraiment un rôle d'aiguillon mais
de motivateur de voilà on est là pour
les motiver et social aux magliano
entend ce soir il a bien compris tu as
mais le message est lié et à travers moi
le président assure michel logis lui
fait pleinement confiance il sait tout
l'enjeu il en est tout à fait conscient
et je sais que ses équipes et lui il
travaille vraiment activement et nous
serons là pour l'aider sur la
communication et sur la reconnaissance
de l'équipement pour le faire
fonctionner au mieux serait de revenir
quelques années avant et 2009 notamment
pour inciter à linge âge qui était à
l'époque premier maire adjoint de la
ville de la verrière et en décembre 2009
il s'interroger sur l'intérêt de
s'engager financièrement dans un tel
projet entendent en temps de crise
qu'est ce que vous en pensez quel regard
vous vous jetez moi je pense de fait
c'est dans les villages au regard de la
question est ce que dans leur majorité
est ce que c'était c'est un c'était le
rôle d'une casquette engagé comme ça
dans la pour devenir propriétaire en
trente ans d'un vélodrome
je pense que c'est drôle de culte et
d'allumer le sk pas trop de danger
finances n'y a pas trop n'y a pas de
donges et financier en tant que tel je
joue un bon exemple quand vous avez un
territoire commune que la comité
d'agglomération 144 d'habitants demain
je l'espère de 100000 surtout pas
d'ailleurs 800000 il vous faut des
éléments structurants du territoire des
éléments visibles des éléments qui font
ça ça d'accord pour la visibilité pour
l'engagement financier ça participe
serre que vos éléments str4 millions
ceux qui font ces sommes importantes
tous les angles mais il faut jamais
sortir l'équipement de l'intérêt pour le
territoire
l'attractivité du territoire ça vous
avez de recettes directes c'est le
montant du partenariat public privé est
élevée toutes les recettes indirectes
jeunes explique quand vous avez une
activité dans ce lieu vous allez avoir
vos attaques qui se remplissent quand
vous avez les qualités dans ce lieu les
restaurants vont se remplir
quand vous avez des activités dans ce
lieu il est connu quand une entreprise
cherche un siège social elle recherche
un territoire dynamique de la visibilité
de la reconnaissance vous aurez plus de
facilité à faire occuper les entreprises
à les faire venir sur quand vous c'était
un bon investissement c'est ce que vous
remettiez avant là pour moi c'est un
investissement qui parachève deux autres
investissements majeurs la présence du
golf national
la présence du théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines est ce qu'on a pu
dire est ce qu'on dirait aujourd'hui que
créer un théâtre national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'était pas un
bon investissement c'est également un
investissement qui se veut de donner de
la notoriété mais également de permettre
au plus proche de nous de pouvoir aller
voir aller à la culture eh bien il faut
de même il faut aller dans le spot en
trente ans quand la casse qui va se
retrouver propriétaire du mastodonte
comme le vélodrome il y aura
certainement des travaux à faire faire
forcément le métro mourad sa sombre
finances ça commence à me guette c'est
pas là-dessus encore une fois moins de
30 ans je ne suis pas inquiet
l'unc et ça les gens regardent des
princes il a beaucoup plus de 30 ans et
il ya aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui résiste
bien à la crise
oui c'est il faut des recettes il faut
développer la partie événementielle
cette prison ce pas d'inquiétude
c'est l'enjeu c'est le challenge est au
contraire si on n'y croyait pas et
d'ailleurs c'est un très bon exemple si
je peux me permettre de quelque chose
qui est apolitique
j'entends bien que monsieur le maire de
verrières ait pu dire ça à l'époque
néanmoins cet équipement a été construit
dans un esprit totalement collaboratif
entre l'ancienne majorité de gauche est
aujourd'hui la majorité de centre et de
droite et je n'ai pas entendu que ça
pose de problème je sais bien également
que ce maire de trains étaient contre il
est toujours contre d'ailleurs mais dans
son apparence mais la casse qui
néanmoins la majorité s'est exprimée au
sujet et la majorité qui a voté cet
équipement était une majorité de gauche
de droite et les gens je rappelle y
avait un collective et le drame aussi
qui s'était créée pour s'opposer à la
kung fu de force a cédé pour le respect
c'est l'aspect écologique vieux la
protection de certains types d'animaux
donc deux fameux triton crêté dont on
rigole beaucoup aujourd'hui mais qui
avait une réalité des clients sans
papiers et qui est et qui est sauvegardé
écuyer sauvegardées sur place la merci
en tout cas elles auront besoin pour
votre éclairage précieux compris les le
financement du vélodrome vous attend
dans le drôme ainsi que tous ceux qui
nous regardent donc nous attendons avec
impatience concernant l équipement il
est saint quentinois on heureux qu'il
soit 51 merci en tout cas devenue sur
pato et 7,8 société on va maintenant
quitter le financement du vélodrome pour
s'intéresser aux futurs championnats du
monde avec arnaud courtier a tout de
suite
allez on poursuit cette huit sociétés
avec voir nos courtiers bonsoir vous
êtes directeur le délégué général chargé
des championnats du monde sur piste us
et il est champion du monde je le
rappelle ce sera du 18 au 22 février
prochain au vélodrome c'est vraiment le
moment phare la dernière fois que la
france a accueilli championne du monde
c'était en 2006 à bordeaux
bonsoir oui c'est le moment phare
effectivement puisque c'est le grand
rendez vous annuel de la pisse et que
cette année en 2015 ce sera au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 13
mois ou 12 mois treize mois après son
ouverture aux mois après son
inauguration avait le droit comme ça des
championnats du monde sur piste du cio
on se dit ouah c'est rapide
waouh c'est ça c'est exactement c'est le
mot c'est rapide d'assez c'est aussi une
vraie fierté française
le groupe national
et la fédération française de cyclisme
avec la communauté d'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines ont beaucoup
travaillé pour ce lot drôme existe et le
fait qu'on reçoive des championnats du
monde
un an après seulement après son
ouverture vient légitimer tout le
travail qui a été fait soit là parce que
ça me wade est déjà mature ce vélodrome
il est mature en alors il a rêvé 6 ha
oui il est mature il est agréé aux
dernières normes de l'ue si donc il est
tout à fait apte à recevoir une
compétition de ce niveau et c'est pour
ça qu'elle nous a été attribuée donc le
vélodrome est à 100% après il reste 28
jours heureusement qu est ce qu il reste
encore à organiser au pas mal de choses
au niveau logistique mais qui se met en
place selon un calendrier prévu toutes
les équipes travaillent pour que tout
soit prêt et tout sera prêt combien d'
équipes seront présentes
alors on a 35 nations présentes ça
représente à peu près de 170 à 300
athlètes parmi les nations un peu
étonnante on peut trouver aux étonnantes
jeu je n'en sais pas maintenant
non mais alors il ya les drames n'a
senti qu'ils les grandes nations seront
là que ce soit la france bien sûr en
premier lieu l'angleterre et bien
d'autres il est difficile de se
prononcer exactement à 28 jours de
l'événement puisque la dernière manche
de coupe du monde vient de se terminer à
cali que les inscriptions donc dès mars
seulement officiellement pour les
championnats donc les équipes sont en
train de s'inscrire dans les grandes
équipes seront évidemment au rendez vous
et pour les spectateurs est ce qu'il
reste des places
on dit que les places sont parties très
très vite les l'ouverture de la
billetterie oui les places sont parties
très vite il reste quelques places
dépêchez-vous j'ai envie de dire voilà
il reste quelques places chaque jour pas
beaucoup que ce soit sur internet sur le
site du vélodrome nationale ou au
guichet du vélodrome tout simplement
vous pouvez acheter encore quatre places
spectateurs pour ce type de compétition
la jauge maximale du vélodrome et de
5000 spectateurs d'accord et quand vous
dites il reste des places et il en reste
par par journée il en fait à du 18 au 20
e chaque jour mais pas pas beaucoup
quelques centaines peut-être au total
donc il est encore possible de se
procurer des places y est on se rappelle
qu'on rappelle juste que si à trois
disciplines qui seront proposés avec les
ans des championnats du monde loc la
course par vitesse la course d'endurance
et le combiné alors plus en fait au
total
une quinzaine de disciplines avec le
kirin l'omnium la vitesse la vitesse par
équipes et individuel donc il y en a
beaucoup
l'intéressant c'est que sur cinq jours
de compétition il y à des manches
sportives différentes tous les jours
avec des remises de médailles et de
titres de champion du monde chaque jour
donc quel que soit le jour où on peut
venir assister aux championnats du monde
on aura droit à un vrai spectacle
sportif alors 10 35 nations qui devrait
être présenté à l'occasion des
championnats du monde on se dit qu'au
niveau de l'organisation
c'est pas un casse tête mais quand ça se
passe justement cette organisation au
niveau de la logistique
comment vous loger des équipes comment
vous allez accueillir les spectateurs
alors je ne sais pas par un cast est
disons que c'est de l'organisation tout
simplement ce qui est important de
préciser que c'est que cette
organisation est fait en co organisation
avec la fédération bien sûr qui est
organisatrice de l'événement avec vélo
police qui gère le vélodrome nationale
et avec la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui nous
accompagne financièrement et
logistiquement et on a vraiment besoin
de ce soutien les équipes sont logées
majoritairement est quasiment
exclusivement là encore sur saint
quentin en yvelines dans les hôtels les
plus proches du vélodrome nationale où
tout est mis en place est pas de
problèmes de telle riz non total qui
doivent être construits à proximité du
vélodrome ne sont pas encore terminées
non ils ne sont pas ils ne sont pas pour
les championnats du monde mais il ya
beaucoup d'hôtels sur notre territoire
donc ils vont accueillir toutes les
équipes et pour l'accueil des
spectateurs ça va se passer quand ses
choix n'y a pas de parking bien au
niveau du vélodrome
alors il ya très peu de parking ou non
vous dirais le drone c'est un choix mais
grâce à la pleine collaboration et
coopération des parkings voisins que ce
soit
de la gare
du centre commercial qui travaillent
avec nous nous allons pouvoir diriger
les spectateurs qui viennent en voiture
vers ces parkings qui sont tous à
quelques centaines de mètres du
vélodrome carmen personnes mobilisées
pour ce type d'organisation à la fois au
niveau du comité d'organisation
je présume au niveau des aussi des
bénévoles fait peut-être appel à des
bénévoles
oui on a à peu près 150 bénévoles qui
vont travailler avec nous pendant
l'événement sur des missions très divers
très variés aussi bien pour accueillir
le public que sur le centre presse ou
les accréditations par exemple et puis
après tout les services de la fédération
sont mobilisés c'est là les finance la
comptabilité la communication
l'organisation la logistique et je
voulais dit tout à l'heure les équipes
de vélo police et certaines équipes de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi donc si
je devais le calcul et au total
rapidement je vous dirais qu'il ya 80 90
personnes qui ont travaillé à
l'élaboration de ces championnats alors
cédé 2 vélodrome a ouvert il ya un an
mais du coup pour rien dit c'est
championnat ça a été extrêmement rapide
à l'heure dès l'ouverture
voilà 50 ans et bien été désigné comme
accueillant ces championnats du monde ça
s'est fait comme un papa dès l'ouverture
mais presque effectivement même si on
est parti en campagne pour cette
candidature manière un peu tardive mais
en se disant on a un vélodrome flambant
neuf et on doit pouvoir le faire et on
l'a fait donc ça a été effectivement un
délai très très comprimé mais grâce une
fois encore au soutien de deux des
entités ad les comprimés la famille
combien de temps pour une fois que la
décision est tombée six mois six mois
concrètement l'organisation on leur a
faites sur six mois six mois au lieu de
normalement un an et demi quasiment deux
ans dans les délais traditionnels quand
on est directeur général délégué qu'on
est à 28 jours qu'on a eu que six mois
pour se préparer on est quoi on est
fatigué à nos courtiers où on se dit le
plus difficile est fait on n'est pas
fatigués on sera fatigué après on aura
tout le temps d'être fatigué après pour
l'instant on est concentré et on est
surtout tous très motivés toutes les
équipes sont très très heureuse
d'accueillir ces championnats c'est une
vraie motivation c'est fédérateur pour
le travail de la fédération des gens qui
travaillent avec nous donc on est
surtout motivé à votre avis qu'est-ce
qui a fait la différence pour que le
vélodrome plus accueillir aussi
rapidement les championnats du monde
un an après son ouverture le vérifier ou
dans même dans l'équipement lui-même a
fait la différence par rapport à
d'autres j'ai plusieurs éléments le
vélodrome en lui-même bien sûr une fois
encore je le répète mais qui est
flambant neuf dont qui et qui est prêt à
accueillir le monde entier avec une très
très belle piste de 8 mètres de large
qui ont fait une des plus larges du
monde potentiellement prêtres des
records qui pourraient tomber dans ces
championnats
et puis aussi le soutien des
institutions la communauté
d'agglomération bien sûr saint quentin
en yvelines de la région ile-de-france
du conseil général et de l'état qui nous
ont tout de suite accompagné dans cette
candidature ce qui était très important
vis-à-vis de l'union cycliste
internationale ça coûte de l'argent
d'organiser des championnats évidemment
un petit peu oui c'est quoi un petit peu
le budget des championnats du monde est
à peu près d'un million huit cent mille
euros
et ça c'est réparti comment s'est
réparti avec des subventions et ses
réparties avec aussi bien sûr toute la
billetterie qui vient apporter de les
subsides nécessaires à fabriquer ces
championnats justement la billetterie en
moyenne un billet pour assister ce qu'il
reste encore des places pas beaucoup
vous l'avez mais il reste encore des tas
alors en moyenne il faut compter combien
si on veut assister à une journée
en moyenne c'est difficile à dire qu'il
ya des billets à la journée il ya des
packs sur la semaine ya des billets pour
les familles des réductions pour les
habitants de saint quentin pour les
licenciés dont il ya beaucoup de prix
mais ça démarre à 11 euros pour pour un
junior 11 euros pour un spectacle qui
dure en gros de 14h30 à 22h30 donc si
vous le ramener aux couleurs c'est pas
grand chose et dans les meilleures
catégories on est un peu plus de 40
euros donc on est dans une fourchette de
prix très accessibles de n'importe quel
on voit qu'on soit placée au niveau du
vélodrome on a une bonne est exact mais
on est peut-être c'est mieux d'être dans
un virage peu traître c'est plus
impressionnant ça dépend du point de vue
de chacun certains veulent être
rapidement dans les virages mais où
qu'on soit si effectivement ces
avantages on voit parfaitement bien ce
courtier donc là c'est les championnats
du monde sur piste
oui cis qu'il yad'autres grand événement
de cette ampleur prévu au vélodrome
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir faire
encore chaque chose en son temps on y
réfléchit on y travaille et il ya une
vraie volonté effectivement d'amener des
très grands et très beaux événements
vélodrome d'autant que le vélodrome à
cette piste pour la piste mais
il ya aussi la piste de bmx couvertes on
travaille de ce côté-là aussi donc il
est trop tôt pour annoncer quoi que ce
soit mais la volonté est là d'accueillir
des grands événements au vélodrome
national à saint quentin 18 jours la
france aura les honneurs en 10 dates en
on est prêt pour le vélo tout est prêt
le vélodrome et la voilà les pistes sont
là donc du côté cyclisme on est tout à
fait partant évidemment pour cette
candidature pour 2024 et tout est prêt
pour accueillir les athlètes
merci à nos courtiers d'être revenu sur
cette petite société pour nous parler de
ces championnats du monde sur piste
russie qui ont donc lieu du 18 au 22
février et comme vous nous disiez il
reste encore des places pas beaucoup
mais il reste pour les amateurs de
cyclisme donc ça se passera évidemment
du côté du vélodrome de 50 ans d'inertie
beaucoup 7,8 société est terminé merci
de votre attention rendez vous dans
quinze jours pour une nouvelle émission
qui si la note aurait